NICOLAS ROARD: My name is
Nicolas, and this is John.
And we're going to talk to you
today about ContraintLayout,
a new layout for Android.
JOHN HOFORD: What's
Layout all about?
Basically, you need
to position widgets
on the screen based on something
that a UI designer might
have given you, for example.
So you have to lay them out
in some particular fashion
on a screen.
But what happens if you
have another screen that you
have to lay out?
If they're fixed position
on the new screen,
it's not going to look right.
Things are too far away from
the edges, things like that.
Now how many screens
would you actually have
to do if you had to do
every screen out there?
5,400 is a rough number.
That's 90 common screen sizes,
30 languages, landscape,
portrait, many, many devices.
And it'll take you
a really long time.
That's why from the very
beginning Android had Layouts.
They're able to adjust sizes
and position things dynamically
for you.
There are a bunch of different
layouts we can talk about.
And you could divide them up
into two basic categories,
simple layouts and
complex layouts.
The classic simple
layout is LinearLayout.
Essentially put your
widgets inside of it
and you have a rule, or
column, of buttons or widgets.
Now you can build
very complex layouts
with just using LinearLayout
by doing deep nesting.
But deep nesting it has
its performance problems.
On the other hand, if
you use a ComplexLayout
like RelativeLayout
or GridLayout,
it'll create
shallow hierarchies.
But without a good UI
builder to use them,
it's actually very difficult
to keep them stable.
We need something new to
help us with that stuff.
NICOLAS ROARD: And so
that's why we are presenting
you ConstraintLayouts.
So it's available on
the new 100 Studio 2.2
Preview in the canary build.
And basically it's a
small unbundled library.
It's actually backward
compatible back to Gingerbread,
to API level 9.
That means nearly
everything out there.
And it's designed to
reduce deep hierarchies.
And it's designed from
the very beginning
to work within Studio.
And if you have started to look
a little bit at ContraintLayout
already, it might look a
little bit like RelativeLayout.
You set traditions
between different widgets,
and that seems pretty
similar to what
ContraintLayout regular does.
Well sure, but actually
ContraintLayout
does what RelativeLayout
does, but more.
And as it is more
expressive, you
should be able to
reduce nesting.
And as John said,
nesting in general
would not be a great thing
for your performances.
It's also packaged as
an unbundled library.
Which means that not only
can you use it from day one,
but we will also be able to
regularly curate on it and push
newer versions,
add new features,
and you'll be able to
get them instantly.
It's also extensible
in its design, which
you don't care too much
about, apart that from
that it allows us to
easily add new features.
And finally it comes
with a great UI builder.
As I said it was really created
as the same team actually.
The same team worked on both
the ContraintLayout and the UI
builder.
And we really tried to
make a UI builder that
is flexible and easy to use,
and really try to help you.
So when we started to think
about creating a new Layout
system, because
we were not super
happy with the current
design, we just
started with something
very generic.
OK, we needed an
equation solver.
And on top of that
we had equations.
But the problem with that
is-- with the equations--
we could have stopped there.
We could have said, you have
equations, that's great.
Just draw equation, put
your Layouts, and that's it.
But the issue with that is,
it's actually very easy,
we found out, to create systems
that are not only complex,
may not perform
really well, and also
can even be unpredictable
in the way they react.
So that's why we built, on
top of the equation system,
a very simple but
pretty expressive
system of constraints.
And that allows us to control
the type of constraints
and the type of
equation that runs,
and I'm sure better
performances.
On top of that we then built the
UI builder plus inference tools
to create the constraint for
you, and a bunch of other tools
that we will demo later.
So very quick overview
of the concert model.
If you want to
create a connection,
you just drag from an
encore to a target.
And the other
thing you can do is
if you simply drag
that widget, you
can actually specify a margin.
And that's all a connection is.
It's saying take one
side, move it to a target,
and possibly keep
a specific gap.
And you can apply
those connections
on of course top, bottom, left,
right, or start on the end
for right to left languages.
We also support baseline.
And at first glance, that it's.
The other thing that is
different and particularly
relative to
RelativeLayout is what
happens if you actually set
the connection on both ends,
both on the left
and on the right.
And if you have a widget that
actually is fixed size that
sounds impossible, right?
The left side cannot be matching
its constraint at the same time
as the right side of the
constraint if the widget does
not resize.
So what we do in that case
is that we just center it.
And because it's centered
and we can tweak the result,
we'll let you decide
how much bias you
want on one side or the other.
And you can also do that
directly into the UI builder,
just drag in and out,
or use the Inspector.
Another option
that we provide is,
what if you want
to resize widget?
And in that case think
about it like match_parent.
And actually we do not
support match_parent.
But what we do support
is something that's
more like match constraint.
And what that will do
is resize the widget so
that the constraint that you
define the size of the widget.
And those are
important aspects that
often comes when you try to do
complex behavior in your UI.
Because what happens when you
want the widget to be gone?
The first case is the
widget is invisible.
If you do that nothing changes.
That's easy, just
not drawn on screen.
But for gone what we do
is we collapse the widget
that you marked as
gone as a single point,
and we discard its margins.
So it completely disappears,
but the actual hierarchy
of constraint still applies.
And so that allows you to
have a lot more reactive user
interface behaviors.
All right, some of you
might have one other,
but what are the attributes?
And yes we did build
a great UI builder,
and we do think that
UI builder will really
help you create those UIs and
really make your life easy.
But if you do want to use
the XML, or the programming,
or do the UI programmatically,
you can still do it.
It's a normal view group.
You still have
access to everything.
So if you look at those
attributes it sounds like,
wow there is a lot.
But actually not so much.
If you look at the those,
those fonts are the usual ones.
Justifying the way of the
size, the text size, and stuff
like that.
Nothing to do with us really.
Then you've got a
bunch of attributes,
and so we can discard those.
Then we've got a
bunch of attributes
that actually, as the prefix
indicates, for the tool.
It's just for Android Studio.
If you do things
problematically you
don't care about that at all.
And in fact, when
you push to a device,
those attributes
get stripped out.
So really the one we care about
are those four in the middle.
And really on those
four in the middle
the margins start on top.
You probably know them already.
So we only have two
more attributes.
So just say you have a
constraint on the left
and a constraint on the top.
So it's actually
pretty tractable.
That said, we really think
that the UA builder is great.
And in fact if you have
issues with the UA builder,
if it doesn't work for
your workflow, tell us.
We really want to hear
from you because we really
want to make your life easy.
All right, let's talk about
the Layout editor itself.
So it's 2-way editing.
We can edit XML and see
the results directly live.
In this version you can edit
UI and that will directly
translate to the XML.
You can have both
views at the same time
or you can stay
in the design mode
if you're going to
edit into Studio.
And we really try to
make it so that there
is an immediate feedback.
And so it's really easy to use.
Things get predictable
and you're not
surprised like you might
have been in the past
with RelativeLayout, with
whatever the Layout decided--
wherever it decided
to put the widgets.
And it's in active development.
We just released
it in 2.2 Preview.
It's not far.
We definitely
welcome back reports.
All right, do you
want to talk about it?
JOHN HOFORD: OK, one of the
nice things that the new Layout
editor has is the inspector.
This gives you iconified
view of a single widget
that you have selected.
The arrows on the left and
right, the lines on the left
and right and up
and down show you
which sides have
been constrained.
The numbers show you the
margins that have been set.
And you can actually just
move your mouse over them
and edit the margins directly.
The sliders allow
you to adjust bias
if you're connected on both
sides so you have a bias.
The little arrows inside show
the wrap content, or spread,
or fixed width.
OK, let's go to the demo
now and on the laptop.
NICOLAS ROARD: All right, so
you can see the-- that's Studio,
and if you have
played with it already
that should be familiar.
And you can see here it just
shows the ContraintLayout.
And I can switch
the design mode.
And we have those two modes.
We have the design mode
where it shows what
things look like on the device.
and you have the blueprint mode.
And you can also have both
of them at the same time
if you prefer.
So why did we do
the blueprint mode?
Well simply because
sometimes what you show,
in terms of Layout,
doesn't actually
appear in the design surface.
Like for example, if
you look at a button,
the button shows smaller than
what its actually bonds are.
So the blueprint
mode, think about it
as an x-ray of your
current Layout,
and only shows you
the information
that pertains to the Layout.
So with ContraintLayout
you can just go and drag
wherever you want.
And you do have some guidelines
to help you position amounts.
We followed the material
design guideline for instance.
And it's very easy to use.
You can, without doing
any constraint so far,
you can still move
it wherever you want.
That's really good
when you're simply
playing around or trying to
design your UI testing to see
how things really fit.
So if you create a connection
we just animate directly.
And you can see that if I
don't create the connection
we still show you what
will happen if you release
and create the connection.
And it actually works
with the entire system.
So if I drag a button and I
then touch this button here
and I kill this connection
everything moves together.
So, and you can see here, it's
only constraint or is untidy
so vertically nothing changes
and I can create a connection
manually like that.
You can destroy all the
connection by clicking this
and just align your things
and create this connection.
There are two different
modes to create connections.
One is this manual
one, and I think
it's very important
because we want
you to be able to easily
tweak the resulting UI.
But there is another one
that's a little bit more
easy to use in some cases,
which is the Auto Alignments.
And if we go on
Auto Alignments--
let me go back on that.
So Auto Alignment works with
this icon here, this little U
shaped magnet.
And what happens
now, if that is on,
is that if I put my
widget on a guideline
it will create this connection.
And you can see that there
is this small animation.
As long as the animation
is not finished
I can still move things around.
But if I let it go
then the widgets
will actually be constrained.
So if I actually resize--
oops there is a bug.
If I resize that,
yeah we bring back,
but you can see that the
constraints are applied.
And I think we talk
about the tools now.
JOHN HOFORD: One more
piece of Auto Alignment
that you might have forgotten.
One of the nice things
about Auto Alignment
is that when you put an
object like this, the fact
that you see the guidelines
allows it to connect.
So as long as you can
see the guidelines,
you'll be able to let it go
and it will connect for you.
So it can be a quick way,
especially for a very simple
UIs, to be built.
The next thing I want to show
you is what we call UI Tools.
So because we are so much a
rich UI Layout type environment,
we wanted to add tools that
were a lot like the stuff
that you would see in
PowerPoint or any of the Visio
or any of the graphical tools.
So at the top you'll see
a collection of widgets,
and they work in
sort of standard ways
where-- let me undo
the-- they would
align left, right, middle,
that kind of thing.
There's a special mode if you
have the magnet turned on.
When you issue
those it'll actually
create constraints for you.
So if you care about having the
constraints very specifically
left align, you can use this to
tell you how would that happen.
NICOLAS ROARD: And in
fact it's kind of how
we want the tool to be used.
We want it to be using
a very flexible way.
Some people might just,
as they go along, just
create the constraint.
Or some people might
just prefer to layout
the widget in a nice place and
then build the constraints.
It's really up to you.
JOHN HOFORD: So it helps
in a lot of situations
like this, where you're just
aligning things, putting things
together like this, setting up.
And you can see fairly
quickly I can come up
with a reasonable amount of
alignment and packing of things
in ways that we
would like to use it.
OK, for the next piece I want
to-- let's go to the next one.
For the next piece, I want to
talk to you about inference.
Now inference is a fairly
complicated system.
NICOLAS ROARD: One second.
JOHN HOFORD: You're
scaring me there.
What we're doing, it's just one
button, the little light bulb
button.
Don't press it yet.
What we do-- where do
you press that button?
We calculate the probability
of all possible connections.
And then we walk
through a series
of heuristically
divined algorithms
which will make
connections for you.
By the end of it, all things
will be properly constrained.
There are a couple of
things-- it's a bit magical.
But there are a couple of
things to remember about it.
Three things to
remember, it'll never
really move a widget on you.
It will apply constraints
wherever you've
left your widgets beforehand.
So it's not going to suddenly
push a widget off the screen
or something like that.
It will do some small
changes whenever
there is-- trying to do
an alignment of things,
but that's OK.
By the end of the
pass, all of the things
are guaranteed to
be constrained.
If you have a
constraint beforehand,
it will honor those constraints.
So it will never destroy
an existing constraint
that you have created.
So you can create
constraints and then
let it finish the job for you.
And in fact, in the demos
you saw, a lot of them
were some manually
created constraints.
Sometimes it will
do auto constraint.
Go ahead, Nicholas,
press the button.
Let's see what happens.
So there you see it.
It made a bunch of constraints.
Its aligned everything.
Now resize the widget.
Resize the screen.
So that was done
just by drawing out
the widgets in the right
space and it can align them.
If you didn't like a
particular constraint it made,
you could change it yourself or
you could add a new constraint.
Add one.
NICOLAS ROARD:
So, for example, I
can still go and just
destroy those connections.
And actually I really
wanted that one
to be connected on the top.
And actually here you can see
that we have a couple of mods
to create this connection.
So by default, it
creates, with the margin
you indicate, in
the toolbar on top.
But if I press
Control it actually
will create a margin with
the current distance.
And sometimes
that's kind of nice
because if you just want
to create the constraint
but you are actually happy with
the current way the widgets are
positioned, that's a time saver.
JOHN HOFORD: So another
thing you can do
is if you have already
laid out and you
added a bunch of
constraints to stuff
but you needed one more
piece of UI on the system.
Add some new piece
of UI in there.
NICOLAS ROARD: It's OK.
JOHN HOFORD: Now you can
just press the button again.
NICOLAS ROARD: Yeah, and as
you saw when I dragged it,
because the auto connect was
on, it automatically tried
to create those connections.
But you can also do
it with auto infer.
JOHN HOFORD: And
you see it added
all the constraints needed
to fill in that other widget.
NICOLAS ROARD: And you can see
that the constraint that it
created was not exactly the
same as the auto connection one.
And that's actually
because auto connect only
look at the amounts
that are close to you.
So that's why it shows
you those guidelines.
And those guidelines, if you
drop the widget at this moment,
will create a constraint where
the guidelines originate from.
The auto inference, on the other
hand, look at the big picture.
JOHN HOFORD: So it might pick
things based on alignments.
The probabilities are fairly
complicated and in the future
we are trying to do more
advanced algorithms in there.
OK, go.
NICOLAS ROARD: I want to
repeat what John said earlier
and it's very important.
The auto inference is not
going to move things around,
it will actually very hard
try to keep the widget
where you put them.
So that means that if you're
not happy with the result
you can still go
back and edit it.
And it also tries to make the
connection that makes sense.
That might not be the
connection you had in mind,
but that's the connection
that makes sense when
you look at the entire system.
It doesn't go crazy, that's
what I'm trying to say.
And that's why also
it's important to have
those manual capabilities
to aid the constraint.
Because we see it more
as a symbiotic relation
between you and a tool.
The tool will help you,
might get you there
like 90% of the way,
saves you a ton of time,
and you can just
focus on what's left.
JOHN HOFORD: Even if it doesn't
work out, you can always undo.
NICOLAS ROARD: Yeah.
All right, so let's simply build
something common like a row.
So if I want to create
a row like that,
I can start with-- I can
use the tools as well.
If I just want to center,
I can just do that.
And if I look at the recycle
view now it appears here.
But of course it's
taking all the space.
So if I mark now the construct
layouts to be wrap content,
you can see-- whoops,
there is a refresh--
how it's just integrated like
that into a recycle view.
And you can just continue
and add more stuff.
And that's it.
You can easily to
build your rows.
So it doesn't automatically
have to work with the entire UI.
You can use it of
course for your main UI,
but you can use it for something
as simple as a row like that.
It is just a normal view group.
And you can see the result.
And let me just create--
just show you quickly how you
create a new Layout file.
So you can in Studio Preview
2.2, let's see, demo.
You just go here and
type ContraintLayout.
And what that will do--
it will create the file.
It actually will automatically
add, if that was not the case,
the dependency to
the support library
that contains ContraintLayout.
And you can then
build something.
And you can still be
used to design mode,
if you actually
prefer the design
mode that still works fine.
We just, in that case, show
the different constraint
as an overlay on
top of the system.
Or you can just
switch to Blueprint.
I tend to prefer
Blueprint because it just
makes things easier for me
when I'm working on Layout.
But the design mode is
really useful to show you
how things look.
So if you want to just build
the typical dialogue like that,
you could have something
up just like that,
and let's say a couple of--
let's actually use e-mail.
And just plain text
here, up, and then you
can see that, up, the connection
box here, up like that.
And that's it.
And if we were doing anything
else I've got my dialogue here.
And you can see it resize, up,
if the repaint want to repaint.
No it doesn't want to repaint.
JOHN HOFORD: Sorry.
You might want to--
NICOLAS ROARD: So,
and you can still
go back, kill all the
constraints, do the inference.
And you can see
that the inference
does a pretty good job as well.
And you can not here
that we constrain
on the baseline for instance.
And I think that's
about it for the demo.
So we can go back to the slides.
JOHN HOFORD: Yeah, go ahead.
You talk about this stuff.
NICOLAS ROARD:
All right, so just
to summarize a little
bit what we showed you.
So there is a new constraint--
there is a new Layout called
ContraintLayout.
It's a small unbundled library.
It's about 100 kilobytes.
Because it's unbundled we think
we'll be able to move fast
and that new features--
it's really built
on top of a very flexible base.
And what's good for us is that
we can control how fast we
can move on the developments
and to make sure
that the performances
will sustain.
It's compatible with
most everything out there
and it is active
development mode.
I want to emphasize this point.
We just released it this week.
It's coming just as
an alpha preview.
We definitely encourage
you to check it out.
Check to UI builder, and
there's certainly some bugs.
We will fix them.
But the reason we actually
announced it at I/O
was because we think it's ready
enough to gather some feedback.
And that's really
something we are keen on.
We want to hear from you.
Our job is to make
your life easier.
Under UI Builder-- as you saw
the UI Builder is kind of live.
Try to automatically react
to your actions to help you,
to give you some
guidance, and you
can use inference to
create connections.
It really save you time.
But you still have
to manual edition.
You can still go back
and just edit things.
And same as the
ContraintLayout itself, it's
a active development.
It's the same thing
that works on both,
which is why they are really
well integrated together.
So all of that I said
for ContraintLayout
out also definitively
for the UI Builder.
And, by the way, in
Studio 2.2 Preview
there is this new UI
Builder for ContraintLayout,
but there is also a new UI
Builder for the older Layout
that you already use
in your applications.
And if you used the UI
Builder that was there
in previous version of
Studio, that new UI Builder
is definitely a step up.
And for it as well it
will get better over time.
All right, let me talk
briefly about what we have
in mind for the next versions.
So if you remember the slide
from earlier about the solver
and the equation
and the constraints,
clearly we're going
to focus on-- probably
in the short term that's
mostly what we'd be working
on-- improving the performance.
We have a ton of optimization
that we haven't, obvious ones,
that we haven't yet done.
So we really want
to focus on that.
For the equation themselves
that will generate
from the constraints, we
have some interesting ideas
on how to automatically
take them and simplify
them and optimize them.
But for the constraints,
there is a couple of things
that we can do and-- actually
we could have demoed it,
but in addition to
those basic constraints
that we demonstrated, we
have the concept of helpers.
And one of the helpers that we
have in the preview actually
is a guideline object.
So you can create a guideline--
think of Photoshop guideline,
something like that, something
that your designer probably
work with.
And you can just
set a guideline,
make it related to
one side or the other,
or percentage of the
dimension of the container,
and simply constrain your
widget to that guideline.
The interesting thing though
is that this guideline is not
a new layout.
This is just an object
that we use to generate
the right equations.
And we have a ton of ideas of
all the type of virtual object
like that-- that will help you
create more advanced Layouts.
Another thing that did
not make the cut for I/O
but that we know is important,
is that all we've talked so far
and that we demoed lets you
creates constraints, position
constraints, from one to one.
Of course it can
be from one widget
to many widgets
for the two axes.
But its going to be from one
widget to do something else.
And often you want to
actually consider position
in terms of grouping.
You want to say, yeah, sure,
but I want this group of stuff
to be vertically positioned.
And we have a concept
of virtual containers.
And similarly to the
guidelines, those things
don't have to end up
in the view hierarchy.
So once we create them
they will actually
appear in the XML
as normal tags.
So you"ll see them.
But when we inflate the XML we
can then drop them on the floor
and simply use them to
generate the right equations.
So you still have the
power of using groups.
We've got the implication in
terms of the view hierarchy.
You can think of this
one system as a way
of decoupling the layout
from the view hierarchy.
And the shallower
the view hierarchy
the better in terms
of performances.
But there are also other things.
One particular thing that
I'm really keen on exploring
is if you have a very
shallow view hierarchy, that
should make your life a ton
easier dealing with animations.
I think if you try
to do animation
with very deep
nested hierarchies it
can be very annoying,
because something that
is down in the hierarchy
you want it to maybe move
somewhere else.
And it's very difficult
to do right now.
But if you actually do not
have an actual view hierarchy
and everything is kind
of flat, it's much nicer.
And of course for the inference
and tooling we have some
interesting ideas on how to
let you import a setting in 200
Studio .
And the concept is simply we
want to give you a step up.
Don't start from scratch.
If your designer
gives you something
maybe there is something
in what it gives you,
or she gives you,
that we can use.
And finally, John might have
something to say about that.
JOHN HOFORD: So the inference
and the tools combination
that we see a lot of future
of making your life very easy.
So one of the
things we want to do
is back the probability
by machine learning.
So look at what
layouts are out there.
What are all the Google
Layouts that they've created?
And see how they are working.
And try to learn from them.
Tools to help you
more easily beautify
and organize and arrange
your widgets on the screen.
More dynamics
associated with where
I put things on the screen.
It will automatically infer
containers, virtual containers,
and guidelines, and
things like that as well.
So there's a lot of room to
grow in that area as well.
NICOLAS ROARD: All right.
Thank you for you attendance.
Check out the code lab.
There's a great
code lab that lets
you-- walk you through the first
steps in using ContraintLayout.
Download the preview.
Beyond the ContraintLayout
there's a new UA Builder.
There's a ton of things, as you
saw in the previous sessions,
are supposed to do.
File bugs, you can use
Tool Studio, a tag.
And we can take some Q&A now
and also mikes that you can
[INAUDIBLE] to if you want.
JOHN HOFORD: OK, thank you.